enfin j'ai trouvé ce servir l'argent
depuis quelques mois
myriam boivin comtois utilise lors de
ses menstruations des serviettes
sanitaires en tissu je voyais le nom
période qu'elle jetait chaque mois que
ce soit d'autre soit le nombre d'années
dans une vie d'une femme puisse trouver
c'est aberrant des chercheurs ont estimé
à 771 millions d'articles d'hygiène
jetables utilisés par les canadiennes
chaque année pour diminuer les déchets
cinq arrondissements à montréal offre
une aide financière à l'achat de
serviettes lavables coupe menstruelle ou
culotte menstruel c'est à dire qu'on a
une compétence qui est la gestion des
matières résiduelles on veut pas juste
ramasser les déchets on veut réduire à
la source trop c'est super intéressant
je trouve ça dur mais des individus ce
programme n'est pas unique à l'île de
montréal plusieurs municipalités dont
saguenay offre la subvention donc
comment on peut voir à l'intérieur c'est
tout pas des de ce côté c'est
l'engouement pour ces produits
écologiques est palpable depuis 2018 sur
les ventes en ligne on a augmenté de 195
% les ventes pareil on commence à être
un peu présente en boutique puis ça
aussi ça fait un très gros bon on est à
plus 150 % à peu près une croissance
rapide
malgré le coup de départ qui en rebute
encore plusieurs
c'est quand même 21 $ pour deux
serviettes mais j'ai calculé l'ensemble
ma période
on estime à 60 $ par année l'achat de
tampons ou serviettes sanitaires
jetables une coupe menstruelle coûte 40
$ pour une durée de cinq ans un kit de
départ de culotte menstruel aussi entre
115 et 300 dollars lorsque la v2 fois
par cycle je pense que la subvention
c'est comme le coup de pouce qui fait
qu'on va faire le pas certains
s'interrogent pourquoi une ville devrait
payer pour un produit si intime tout le
monde doit payer pour la gestion des
déchets de tout le monde donc si on peut
tous et chacun réduire nos déchets c'est
bon pour tout le monde
une aide financière qui encouragera
myriam a effectué son virage écologique
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada
montréal